é um técnico que nós vamos gravar eu já
não sei que nós vamos gravar hoje
olá pessoal do que fala e quem fala é o
dark preciso muito bem-vindos é mais um
vídeo e o extrato de que não se ainda
vou escolher mas em breve o assunto que
esse time está bom eu tenho que dar uma
olhada no meu facebook o costumeiro que
fosse um dizem lá eu recebi um livro
muito estranho que os links que aparecem
em vídeos parecem que eu seria abrir um
link e outro para mim com uma coisa
extremamente fofa esta fase inicial
expressam ser um jogo assim eu tentei
fazer um vídeo deste site procuro isso
parece muito fofo mas para isso é
interessante porque está tudo em curso e
no japonês chinês não sair a pessoa que
mediu stream que dispor em oitavo no
máximo otto súbito ataque o site chinês
de espírito de mito que ancara que
alguma coisa esclarece que os anúncios
do recto gols com comune as fofas vamos
carregar essa menina então
não não na
a pagar altas
não é pobre
estamos curtindo um susto elas não
saíram ciclos não vou ficar mais perto
que eu agora tenho pensado isso já não
acontece nada aqui na área que é a que
eu tenho que fazer daqui um pontinho aí
eu vou com a cara que eu vou está erro
do windows synergy xp eo windows o que
pensava que o sol sabe é quem faz o
outro erro meu deus eu sabia que espera
vírus para um jogo que faça atacou
defendendo e não saiu voltar português
vou atacar através de consulta eu só com
essa mulher ou eu tenho 80 vida já não
era agora não morreu do coração como eu
tenho vindo de vida só vou usar esta que
ver o que é que eu morri
aí eu morri outra coisa que eu não sei é
um quadrado branco
ai meu deus eu vou tocar aqui eu posso
tocar aqui o seu jogo porque eu tava com
eltinho não conseguir passar aqui onde
estamos para tv poupa-me antes assim eu
sei que vai ter um susto em vôo ou
ocorre que nem sempre uma pontinha a
pouco vamos tentar o segundo agora a nem
isso é coisa do santa na xx mas o brigão
sai on quis voz lesou negociar e vender
carros não sair terei que qualquer coisa
um lado só paraná certamente a pessoa
que registrou drogas fez muito aqui é o
lugar de kaká que talvez molho o envio
por si um vídeo aqui esteve em outubro o
youtube permite estas coisas do satanás
e clipe mesmo eu nem sei o que quero
fazer e will cérebro vai ficar possuído
agora avançado está aqui pop vai
prosseguir de entrega é para quem nao eu
não sei o que está passando eu tenho que
escrever alguma coisa vão tentar fraudar
frame
vamos pesquisar ou o que eu disse que
era um shitara se solicitará mas desiste
mesmo também não só eu deus tá tudo em
geral faz porque vou jogar até mesmo ou
é um site novo sai drogas site mil em
drogas que eu tenho que fazer meu deus é
muito ponteiro pra mim já não aguenta
tanto ponteira tem que pôr o ponteiro na
porta não é isso não um crime por ciúmes
porque sabia que não conseguiria porta
continua à frente sai a eu acho que eu
tenho que passar isso faço importante
para eu conseguir avançar problema
o plano é só isso que eu posso prometer
sobre ela chega é que o boca campanha
chega site o fuxico não visitem o site
por favor não deixaram inscrição para os
mais curiosos mas não visitem tudo que é
sensível mundo então é isso pessoal
enquanto que o vasco é que tu brito foi
bem até a próxima